foreign
comes from Michelle in New York with
student loan payments starting again
soon I'm hearing a lot of people talk
about an unintended consequence will be
a big hit to the economy with that money
going to student loan payments instead
of being spent at retailers they're
saying maybe this could drive us into a
recession do you see this happening
no it's not enough money
it's not big enough it relative to the
size of the gross domestic product the
GDP so there's not a big enough tail
here to wag this dog so mathematically
so I no I don't see that happening
um
and let's just say it did
so what
like these people don't need to pay
their bills just because we might face
no absolutely no so and here's how we
also know it didn't create a recession
did you notice that having all these
people having all this money to spend
did not cause a boom that's true if you
had an extra 400 bucks it wasn't enough
money to cause a an economic boom when
they were all blowing it on vacations as
a matter of fact one study came out last
week Jaden I were reading this the other
day came out said that uh like 80
percent of the people spent all the
money on vacations retail drugs and
alcohol wow
and even well I mean if there's a
recession in the cocaine area that's
probably okay I can deal with that if
there's a little if there's a little
crack recession I think we can handle
that part but uh I'm thinking the
alcohol retailers are probably okay they
made enough money during covet to last
them about 10 years oh they made out
like a Bandits on that oh man it was the
biggest remember the wine bottle stacked
up and the pictures of that at the curb
during the during the during the coveted
quarantine that was like when alcohol
delivery became hot yeah I can't leave
the house you bring it to me yeah and
lots of consumption was a big deal yeah
I'm just saying so anyway all kidding
aside it didn't cause a boom so it won't
cause a bust and that illustrates my
earlier statement that it's not enough
money relative to the size of the
economy to tank the economy because it
didn't make the economy so it won't
break the economy so however what it is
going to do is it's going to put a pinch
on the 99 I cannot believe this number
99 of the people that didn't have to pay
payments on their student loans
didn't pay anything on their student
loans one percent used all of this
chance at no interest to get out of debt
99 took the approximately fifteen
thousand dollars per person that it
saved them and blew it and it's gone and
now they're going to go I don't know my
budget's tight just in time for
Christmas well the scary part is a lot
of people got refunds from their student
loan servicer so the student loan
company here's your 10 grand in payments
back the government will forgive it
you'll be fine they give them 10 grand
reinstate their loan balance and lo and
behold no forgiveness and that puts them
in a real pinch if they spent that money
because most people said well I'll hold
it in savings Humanity has told us that
we don't make great decisions when we
just have a pile of money sitting there
so that's really scary and also people
who bought really expensive cars in the
last few years really expensive houses
in the last few years who now have to
make those payments on top of student
loan payments so could that cause some
foreclosures and repos no you know the
people that went over the edge on stupid
are always going to get caught I did
that once and I got caught so you know
you're just stupid will catch up with
you it's Gotta it's got a real this is
like your skinny dipping line it reminds
me of that one yeah when it was actually
Warren Buffett so it wasn't mine but I
stole it yeah you can tell who's skinny
dipping When the tide goes out so there
you go tide is going out people that's
what's happening prepare yourselves get
clothed yeah but I think I think you're
safe Michelle from a recession uh maybe
not a personal recession but certainly a
national recession